あった
[音楽]
んだ
ん
私はセルフィーが大好きです
ios ソフィー
皆さんせる聞いて何かご存知ですか
ポイントが多いですね
カメラセルフィーステップそしてこういうふうに取ると地鶏千風になります
私はこのセルフィーのこと
さわやかな自己表現と呼んでいます
ベルギーとはなんなんだろう
私はこう呼んでいます
一瞬一種パチパチっと納めることによってその今の瞬間を思い出に残します
今一瞬のワンピース
でも星もとがはこれだけ器セルフィーが大好きな人ではなかったんですね
むしろ自分に対してはすごく自信を持ってない
どんな子どもでした
浅井伸ばしそしてもっとは買え
幼い私です
今は縁を出して d コーともらうことができるんですが
昔はそうなことを言っていません
私はコーンボミ
韓国人です
容姿は韓国人でも9隻も私も書く
しかし生まれは日本です
韓国日本そしてアメリカにも数だことがある
私がいた場所に置いて私はすでにマイノリティでありました
これはこんなことが小学校の時になりましたん
韓国にいた時
お前日本晴れなんだってねぇ
その一言で周りの人がみんな
あああの子は日本晴れだったという意識を持つようになっていじめを受けたことがあり
ました
また小学校5年生の時私が日本に来た時
今度は日本語が話せないそして名前
ウォンボミという読みにくい名前
それによって塾の先生から酷いこと言われたり
木工を投げられたりそういった事件もありました
今振り返れば何度でもまあないような事っていうふうに話せてはいるんですがその当時
の私にとっては自分で決めたことでもないのに生まれながらにして持っていたものなの
それを否定されることによって自分は全してされているかのように感じています
アメリカに行ったときも同様です見た目がこんな感じでアジアページなどでです
人種差別をやろの受けていました
幅を投げつけられたりん
すごく大切に思っていた講師とファミリーに見捨てられたり
ん
ここ戦になっても
そんな感じでした
自分で鏡を見て自分のカウントこう向き合いながら
うーん今日の私もなんか自分らしくないなあと思っ
またやり直しやり直し入っちゃって大変男の縁
来年を見ようとしたんです
いろんなことを試してみましたかッ
難しかったです
そんななか出会ったのがこの本です
モリー先生の火曜日この本をご存じの方はいらっしゃいますか
あまりいなさそうですかねえっ
これは難病 als の病気を持っている
おい先生という
社会学の教授の方が自分の昔の教え子
ミッチーに対して
最後の授業をする人生に関する授業をする本です
2人の廃炉によって生まれますここで
先生はこういます
人生で一番大切なことをそれは
愛し愛されることを学ぶことというふうに言います
愛ってなんだっ
みなさん自分を愛せてますか
私はその時考えてみました
高校生の私中学生私氷河性も私
あいーさーれって1んのかーのー
愛してきたのかなっ
派手だっ
は彼らのことですなので自分が自分を愛してるよそして人に愛されることを受けれ紅緒
というチャレンジを3つ怠っています
行ってみました
一つ目10年に来て new したいん
これによって私は自分自身の日々の日常を一つ一つ
切り刻んで文字に起こしながらピリを振り返っていました
それ以外にもこんなことをしていました2番目の延着ゆうゆう示唆
自分自身をインタビューしているよということで先ほども紹介したのリー先生との
火曜日の方を題材にして自分がそこからどういったことを学んだのか自分と人との
出会いというもので私が何を感じて自分がどういう風に変化してきたの
を書きましたん
本当は一人一人でひとりぼっちの時
燃費の場合はひとりぼっちで自分との対応だったのですが
インタビューの時は私の話を聞いてくれる相手がありました
今日で一人ぼっちではなくなりました
次にはもう少し広く見てみようと思いました
自分と関わるあらゆる人々
日本韓国アメリカで育ちながら関わってきたあらゆるバックグラウンドを持つ
友達
ヒョージュ家族様々な人に自分と相手に関するアンケートを配っていました
室箱僕はなんと35カ所ぐらいあります
35カ所室も項目に対して
200万によるほぼの友達が
にし2カ月の間にこれだけ私のことを考えながら
そして自分の夢などを語って書いてくれました
とてもありがたいことです
自分自身
愛する愛される難しいですよ
思った以上に簡単なことではありませんでした
ただ私は自分から始めてみようと思ったのです
その後どんどん輪を広げていきました
私そして開いてあなた
ねっ私たちのはを作るそこで愛を育む
エンダーつふぁぼを
何かに悩んだり迷ったりすると春せよという言葉があります
私はいろんなこういった経験をして自分を愛し
また相手を愛し愛されること
を経営落としたのですがそれは結構ごく一部
私の boundary の中にある人たちのみのことがなあというふうに思いました
なのでその自分が守られている空間
たらそこに出て他の人たちはどうなのか
てみよう
チャレンジしてみようと思い休学を決断し
世界一周にファビョってを描けました
そこで使ったのがこの設定です
仕上げな乙ゲルっ
今この一瞬をみなさんとワタシって一緒に共有する
何によってセルフィーによっ
共有していきましたます
場所にこれは僕は曽田の難しいなんですが友達と撮ったもの
家族と撮ったもの
旅をしながらの日常一日量の中での日常を生み出しながら日々を私は
収めてきました
これはフランスのあるビーチ
創薬をしながら私は世界中の旅をしていたのですがその時の仲間たちとまたそのビーチ
で初めて出会った5人の仲間と一緒に整備を撮りました
初めはお互いにうーんなんか隣に座ってる子っぽいかけてみようかなというくらいで
始まった会話だったのですが
来館盛り上がって以外のところで共通の友達がいるということに気付き
こういうふうにセルフィーに収めることができました
これを一つの私の表現だったと思います
次いきます
k
ファンと乗っていた車がボロボロに詰まってしまいました
それで乗っていたみんなが降りて車を押す羽目になったのですが結構重くて
ちっとは太田だったのです
みんなで協力して動かしてなんとかこのハプニングを乗り越えました
それが期限としてとっだ一つのセルフィー動画です
またここは水素電車の中でしたん
彼二人いますが二人とも宮税
私がたまたま乗った列車の中で隣に座ってば人たちです
より落ちながらみんなでこの偶然の出会いを感謝し楽しみました
音がと右にいるカレコ
右の電車でをたまたま一緒で入りに電車を全く違う方向に進んでたのにまた同じ車両に
乗っててビックリしたという
できました
この数字は何かご存知ですか
13312ん
私が icu 国際基督教大学に来て4年目になりますがこの4年間で撮ったセル
フィーの数です
ここの最後の3つの数字31に私の誕生日でもあります
一つ一つの写真を見返しながら数えていった結果
なんと自分の誕生日自分の存在をその中で見いだすことができました
これ私は生理ピティと言いによります
男性に出会うそして良き制度八景をすること
セルフィーを撮ることによっていっ
意外と私たちはこのセレンディピティの可能性を広げることができると思ったのです
なので皆さんにぜひしてにしてほしいことがあります
セルフィーはずセグソフィ稚魚分
カメラを持っていらっしゃる方また持ってない方もいらっしゃると思いますがその場合
は隣の人を交えてあげて
セルフィを今一緒に撮ってみましょう8皆さんが死後準備しますのでカメラを持って
ください
携帯を持ってるのはいらっしゃいますか i と思う方いらっしゃいません
ではは以下の方お願いします
私は瀬戸いく再修理相談する初めての機会なのでぜひ皆さんと一緒にいないと思って
このスペックを持ってきました
なのでぜひ笑顔で写ってください
見えましたみなさーん
いきます最高のようでさあ
re
では皆さんくださいん
この1枚のセルフ私にとっては誰だかた講談の記念のものになってるかもしれませんが
これ後で皆さん一人一人で仲良くなった時にあんとき私実は一番州立ってなんだよと
いう話を挙げたになるかもしれません
セルフ1枚によって人の出会いさというものを改めて認識することができると思います
すごく簡単でしょカメラと事物合えば行きたいですよね
皆さんちゃんと撮りましたかー
あとでさーああ
はいっ
ここで得られた曲 no 勇者を尿は誰です
no 優勝やオーダーです
自分自身を否定し続けていた私それは紛れもなく他の人他の人の言葉によって傷つけ
られた私の心の中に原因があったと言う
私を持ってい
自分を指定し続ければ本当に相手のことで愛せるのでしょうか
私はそうではないと思いました
まず自分ひとりから自分を愛する努力をしてその自分の中でのは他の人にどんどん広げ
ていった結果自分のことを知ることもでき場所をすることもできそしてうわぁを築く
ことができました
よくと愛して愛されることをまだ抜けがちょっとだけしました
最後の話として私がなぜこの今1周
セルフィーを撮ることにこれだけ執着しているのかをみなさんにちょっとだけ共有し
たいと思います
実は9月5日後小骨事故に遭いました
9写真にも見えるほど首の部分の骨があまり良くない状態になってしまい
また左全身打撲の状態でした
未だに病院は通院している状態が打つな
今バイブこうして元気に立てば滑っ
そこでもってやはり自分自身が死を目の前にして
自分の周りにいる人がどこでん
どういうふうになくなるかわからないということです
こうして隣にいた友達今隣に座ってる人たち
明日には会えなくなるかもしれないん
しかもそれがエイミーアワーとなるかも知れ
そう思うと今機種を一緒に入るタイミングをこの思い出を共有したいというふうに思い
ませんか
私はぜひ皆さんとこういうふうにこの一瞬しを大事にしてき
思い出を共有していきたいなというふうに思います
このセルフィーを通してみなさんも自分自身そして周りの人たちを ic
また愛される存在として最人気し再認識してみたはいかがでしょうか
ハピなぁ以上になります
[拍手]
フープ